es ist der bisher größte in der JVA Köln
Ossendorf Gentleman gibt ein Konzert im
Knast was er nicht weiß er wird hier
länger bleiben als im lieb
ist doch erstmal sorgt der regy Star für
Stimmung die Inhaftierten sind hin und
weg das war das beste was ich bis jetzt
hier gesehen habe we das auch meine
Richtung von Musik ist ich mich
natürlich auch total gefreut war eine
super Abwechslung für den Haftalltag ja
und klar ist natürlich was ganz anderes
Mal Gentleman kennenzulernen und vor
allem auch live zu sehen und in so einem
kleinen Rahmen super erste Reihe ganz
toll Gentleman versetzt die Gefangenen
nahezu in
Ektase doch nach dem Konzert heißt es
warten es ist niemand da der Gentleman
freilassen
könnte
drei inhaftierte nutzen die Chance für
ein ganz persönliches
Andenken
mamazi oh das war voll schön
gchelt ja wer will denn jetzt Frage ja
okay können wir noch ein Foto mit klar
Ken wir auch alleine Foto machen
be unter die Nase re ich ma das erste
Foto oh du lächelst
sogar so mal liebe Leute also man muss
das jetzt
dokumentieren gentl kommt nichtus von
der Presse Management und Leute die auch
hingehören sind eingesperrt wie kommt
das mit Gentlemen wie ist das öfter hier
so ich meine ich habe es ja befürchtet
dass wir hier nicht mehr rauskommen aber
warum ja weil du da
bist wohl du hast ihn den Flieger
verpassen lass dein Spirit das ist mein
Spirit immer eingesperrt sein passiert
immer irgendw das ist schlimm jedes Mal
wenn ich mit dem Interview mache
irgendwie ist irgendwas
okay eingespert ne eingesperrt kann kann
man auch ausgesperrt sagen ausgesperrt
beim Letten Mal hat er beim letzten Mal
hat er sein Flieger verpasst ver den
Flieger haben wir auch schonör den
ersten Flieger seit Jahren W gemerkt
Christop
weiß gar nicht wir hab glaub ich einmal
Flieger ver in Paris minan nach London
so des der blöde krachten und so der
meinte so ich sag dir bescheid muss ich
ab so ja ja wir achten dann da drauf und
dann so das gesagt und dann so wir haben
5 uhor noch eine Frage ich muss los
jetzt komm noch eine ja okay da sieht
man der Presse kan man nicht trauen nee
das ist wohl
wahr Gentleman nimmt es gelassen ja
Gentlemen wie findest du es hier so fest
zuitzen wir haben super Gesellschaft wir
haben Essen und Trinken irgendwie also
ich bin guter Dinge wir haben gesagt wir
kommen wieder und jetzt überlegen wir
jetzt bleiben wir direkt hier dann
brauchen wir auch nicht wiederkmen dann
sind wir ja schon
hier nach einer knappen Stunde kommt
endlich ein befreiungstrupp doch der hat
seinen Preis ein Foto muss noch
seinall hallo
H
ja immer wenn der Krach dabei ist geht
was in die
Hose